This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听《艰难成长的学问》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的生活经历，进行一些在其他地方真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人带着盔甲出行。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，收听《艰难成长的学问》
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次之多，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困的爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《百分之二》（2%）中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇异的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。经历一些困难，你将迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《百分之二》。也就是数字2加percent，在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. I say this every time. I'm so excited for today's episode, but perhaps the most excited I've ever been because today we have a very, very special honored guest. Would you like to introduce yourself? Yes. Hello, everybody. I am Chedera Agarroo. I'm popularly known online as the slumflower. You may know me as the author of Water's time to be alone or you might even remember me as the creator of the viral movement hashtag saggy boobs matter if you are even newer here you might have discovered me from my podcast the slumflower hour and i'm super grateful and excited and pumped to be on jemma's podcast because we have
相信你的闺蜜。在IHeart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（the girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（the psychology of your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化与转折，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎新老听众回到这个播客。我每次都这么说。我对今天的节目感到非常兴奋，但这也许是我有史以来最兴奋的一次，因为今天我们迎来了一位非常非常特殊、备受尊崇的嘉宾。你想自我介绍一下吗？好的。大家好。我是切德拉·阿加鲁（Chedera Agarroo）。我在网上更广为人知的名字是“贫民窟之花”（the slumflower）。你可能知道我是《是时候独自一人了》（Water's time to be alone）的作者，或者你甚至还记得我是病毒式传播运动话题标签“下垂的乳房也很重要”（#saggy boobs matter）的创作者。如果你是这里的新面孔，你可能是通过我的播客《贫民窟之花时间》（the slumflower hour）发现我的，我非常感激、兴奋和激动能来到杰玛（Jemma）的播客，因为我们有
so much to dive into and discuss and i think this is just the perfect collision of worlds i could not agree more couldn't agree more this is the collab that needed to happen um and I would, like, Chedera is a legend. I have known about her since I was 17, 18 years old. It's a full circle moment. Honestly, I'm starstruck. Like, we've obviously spoken before, but I'm starstruck that you were willing to come on. I also think a huge shout out to her podcast, which she started at the end of last year. We're going to talk about it a little bit more, I'm sure, during the course of this episode, but if you are not listening to it already, I don't know what you're doing, because it's just, it's like the Bible. It's like an audio book of the Bible, but even better.
太多内容要深入探讨和交流了，我认为这简直是两个世界的完美交融。我完全同意，完全同意。这是期待已久的合作，嗯，而且我想说，切德拉是个传奇人物。我从17、18岁起就知道她了。这是一个圆满的时刻。说实话，我感到像追星一样崇拜。就像我们之前显然有过交流，但我还是很惊叹你竟然愿意来参加。我还想对她的播客大加赞赏，那是她去年底开始做的。我相信在本期节目的过程中我们会更多地谈到它，但如果你还没在听的话，我不知道你在干什么，因为它简直就像圣经。它就像圣经的有声书，但甚至更好。
Do you want to describe how we met? I feel like that would be interesting. Oh, like, first of all, we have to give a very important shout-outs to Evie, who essentially, I feel like she brought us together. I feel like she was in both of our ears being like, you both need to be on each other's podcast you both need to speak you both need to meet and we had we ended me and jemma ended up jumping on a zoom together it was supposed to be just like a super brief call to just familiarize ourselves of each other and gloss through topics we might want to dive into and before you know it we were on we actually you know zoom's got this thing now where 40 minutes in it will give you like a countdown we literally waited for the countdown 40 minutes in and then we started a whole other zoom again
你想描述一下我们是怎么认识的吗？我觉得那会很有趣。哦，首先，我们要对伊维（Evie）表达非常重要的感谢，基本上我觉得是她把我们聚到了一起。我觉得她在我们两个人的耳边说，你们两个需要去上对方的播客，你们两个需要谈谈，你们两个需要见面。结果我和杰玛跳进了一个Zoom会议，本来应该只是一个超级简短的通话，让我们彼此熟悉一下，顺便浏览一下我们可能想深入探讨的话题。还没等你反应过来，我们在Zoom上——其实你知Zoom现在有个功能，40分钟时它会给你一个倒计时。我们真的就等了40分钟的倒计时，然后我们又开启了另一个全新的Zoom会议。
I think we were on for like two hours or something literally Yeah, it was 1 a.m. in Sydney when I finished the call and I was like, I could have gone for longer. And we talked about like, it wasn't like surface level information. It was like, we talked about childhood trauma. We talked about astrology science. We dived into our dynamics and our relationships with men. And then we decided that we were going to be best friends. So, um, welcome.
我想我们当时聊了大概两个小时左右吧，真的。是的，我结束通话时，悉尼时间已经是凌晨1点，当时我想，我其实还可以聊更久。我们聊的不是那种表面的信息。我们聊了童年创伤。我们聊了占星科学。我们深入探讨了我们与男人的互动模式和关系。然后我们决定我们要成为最好地朋友。所以，嗯，欢迎。
And that's the Pisces effect. That's the Pisces effect. Gemma's a Pisces. So when you're around people who are Pisces energy, like, you just feel like you can open up. And that's what happened. So I'm very happy to be here. And I'm really looking forward to our conversation. And I know we're going to touch on so many things that will relate to the listeners who I'm so grateful for. Yeah. You're absolutely right. And the thing that we really want to talk about today, it's kind of a nuanced topic. But something that I think to Dera, that you do really well is talk about
这就是双鱼座效应。这就是双鱼座效应。杰玛是双鱼座。所以当你在散发双鱼座能量的人身边时，你会觉得自己能够敞开心扉。这就是发生的事情。所以我很高兴来到这里。我非常期待我们的对话。我知道我们将触及很多与听众相关的话题，对此我非常感激。是的。你说得绝对没错。我们今天真正想谈论的事情，其实是一个挺微妙的话题。但我觉得切德拉你做得特别好的一点是，你谈论了
how we can almost relearn how we have relationships with men and how we can address the internalized misogyny and the patriarchy that kind of flows through all of us, especially people who identify as women, that impacts our relationship with men, that impacts our dating lives. And I think we're both women in our 20s, and it's so relevant to understand where exactly
我们如何几乎是重新学习如何与男性建立关系，以及我们如何应对内化的厌女症和潜伏在我们所有人当中的父权制——尤其是那些自我认同为女性的人——它如何影响我们与男性的关系，如何影响我们的约会生活。我认为我们都是二十多岁的女性，去理解我们的互动模式以及我们对待关系的方式到底源自何处，
our dynamics and how we approach relationships come from and to relearn some of those things that we've learned early in childhood. Like I know that you speak quite a bit about or you have spoken to me about your parental relationships and how attachment styles really do define how we approach dating. Do you want to talk a bit about this more? Because I feel like you had such an interesting perspective the other day. Yes. So when me and Jemar spoke on our Zoom turned adoption of each other, we were discussing attachment styles but I actually took it a step much further back and actually started talking about my relationship with my parents specifically my relationship with my mom so I'm pretty much towards the end of my 20s I'm 28 years old and I haven't been speaking to
以及重新学习那些我们在童年早期学到的一些东西，是极其重要的。我知道你曾多次谈到，或者你曾跟我谈过你的父母关系以及依恋风格是如何真正决定我们的约会方式的。你想多聊聊这个吗？因为我觉得前几天你的视角太有趣了。好的。所以当我和杰玛在我们的Zoom通话中畅谈并“认领”彼此的时候，我们讨论了依恋风格，但我实际上把时间往回推了很远，开始谈论我与父母的关系，特别是与我妈妈的关系。所以我的二十多岁快过完了，我28岁了，而且我从
my mother since 2018 so over five years and it's a decision that I came to on my own because I just knew that it was abusive, especially emotionally, and it continues to be that way, even though I've cut off all contact. And anybody who has had to unfortunately separate themselves from any kind of abusive relationship or situation, especially when the person presents a lot of narcissistic tendencies, knows that as long as that person is still on this planet, they will still find ways to try and reach you and assert their dominion over you. And so being a young person and making the choice to separate from my mother, really actually unknowingly informed the way that I approached men. And you'd think, well, how can there be any kind of comparison or connection between
2018年起就没跟我妈妈说过话了——也就是说已经五年多了。这是我独自做出的决定，因为我清楚地知道那是虐待，尤其是情感上的，而且即使在我切断了所有联系之后，情况依然如此。任何不得不不幸地脱离任何形式的虐待关系或处境的人——尤其是当对方表现出大量自恋倾向时——都知道，只要那个人还留在这个星球上，他们就会想方设法试图联系你，并向你宣示他们对你的统治权。因此，作为一个年轻人，做出与母亲分离的选择，实际上在无形中影响了我对待男性的方式。你可能会想，这怎么可能有什么比较或者联系呢？
dating men and having a mother? And you'll find that the way you were nurtured, the way that you were taught to receive love, the way that you were treated when you advocated for yourself, does set the tone for not just what you accept in relationships with men, but what you anticipate because if you experienced a lack of care and a lack of concern for your emotions from a primary caregiver like a mother, then when you go on to date men and you're still moving through the world with that lack, it often means that when you are seeking romantic partners, you usually go for what's familiar and oftentimes what's familiar doesn't have to feel good for us to feel comfortable. And that was what was happening to me throughout my 20s before I'd
约会男人和一个母亲？你会发现，你被养育的方式，你被教导接受爱的方式，以及当你为自己发声时你所受到的对待，不仅为你接受与男人的关系设定了基调，也为你所期望的设定了基调。因为如果你从像母亲这样的主要照顾者那里经历过关爱的匮乏和对你情感的漠视，那么当你继续与男人约会时，如果带着这种匮乏感在世界上前行，通常意味着当你寻找浪漫伴侣时，你通常会选择你所熟悉的东西，而通常情况下，熟悉的东西并不需要让我们感觉良好就能让我们感到舒适。这就是我整个二十多岁一直在经历的事情，在我意识到发生了什么之前，
realized what's going on where I would end up with men who would make me feel like I have to earn their validation. I'd find myself in situations with men where I would feel quite coerced into doing things with them. And I would even encounter conversations with men where it felt like I was basically begging them for love and proving why I deserve it. And it wasn't until my mid-20s that I started to make the link when I noticed that since I, I had removed the contact I had with my primary caregiver, I noticed that, okay, I've done the scariest thing being walking away from my own parent
我最终总会遇到那些让我觉得必须赢得他们认可的男人。我会发现自己陷入这样一种境地：我觉得自己被强迫去和他们一起做某些事情。我甚至会遇到这样的对话：感觉我基本上是在乞求他们的爱，并证明我为什么配得上它。直到我二十五六岁时，我才开始把这些联系起来。我注意到，自从我断开了与主要照顾者的联系后，我意识到，好吧，我已经做过了最可怕的事情，那就是离开我自己的父母，
and never speaking to them again. Now it feels way less scary to walk away from men who aren't good for me because there isn't that fear of, oh, but what if I don't experience the connection that I need anymore? Because I've already removed myself from what the world would consider the most important connection in my life and I didn't die from it. I'm able to tell this story now with ease
再也不和他们说话。现在，离开那些对我不好的男人感觉远没有那么可怕了，因为没有了那种恐惧，即“哦，万一我再也体验不到我需要的连接怎么办？”因为我已经让自己脱离了世界可能会认为我生命中最重要的连接，而且我并没有因此死去。我现在能够轻描淡写地讲出这个故事，
because I've already lived through the decision, but the decision itself to make it is not easy at all. But I would say that if you are somebody that in any way resonates with the story I've just shared, it's worth really observing the kind of relationship you have with your parents. And if you do have a parent or a caregiver that was abusive towards you at some point in your life, it's really worth your time to look deeper into that.
是因为我已经亲身经历了那个决定，但做出这个决定的过程一点也不轻松。不过我想说，如果你也是那种对刚才分享的故事感同身受的人，真的非常值得去审视一下你与父母的关系。如果你确实有一位父母或照顾者在你人生的某个阶段对你进行过虐待，那真的值得花时间去深入了解。
yourself, how has this enabled the way that I now allow things to just land in my life and not question any of it? How do I operate when I'm around men who present certain similarities that fire up this instinct in me to prove that I'm worthy of love? And what can I do to start practicing that risky feeling of walking away from men who aren't good for me? Because ironically, once you've separated from the main source of pain in your life, if that's main source of pain comes from a parent, everything else becomes easier to walk away from. And that's what I think a lot of people are struggling with. Because they haven't eliminated the main source of that deep pain, that deep trauma, that deep trigger, they're still getting
问问自己，这如何促成了我如今允许事情在生活中发生却不去质疑的态度？当我周围的男人表现出某些相似之处，从而激发了我证明自己值得被爱的本色直觉时，我是如何运作的？我能做些什么来开始练习那种离开对我不好的男人的“危险感”？因为具有讽刺意味的是，一旦你脱离了你生命中主要的痛苦来源——如果那个主要的痛苦来源来自父母——其他所有事情都变得更容易放下了。这也是我认为许多人在苦苦挣扎的原因。因为他们没有消除那种深层痛苦、深层创伤、深层触发点的主要来源，他们依然在不断被
retrigured by people who don't even hold half the importance that the primary caregiver that initially created those triggers even holding their life. Oh my gosh. And that's, I think you're absolutely right. It completely is explained in many ways. by psychology. And I think just to say so much credit to you for making that decision, because we look to our parents, especially in early childhood and in our early development for everything. They are our source of life. And that explains why when we decide that we need to make that break from them, if that's something that you need to do, it's going to be so painful. That's the primary pain, right? That's the first round. And then the second.
那些甚至不具备最初产生这些触发点的主要照顾者一半重要性的人所再次触发。天哪。而且，我觉得你绝对说得对。心理学在很多方面完全解释了这一点。我觉得要对你做出那个决定报以极大的赞赏，因为我们对父母寄予厚望，特别是在幼儿时期和我们的早期发展阶段，他们就是一切。他们是我们生命的源泉。这就解释了为什么当我们决定需要与他们决裂时——如果那是你需要做的事情——过程会如此痛苦。那是最初的痛苦，对吧？那是第一轮。然后第二轮
round comes from having to unlearn what they've taught you implicitly and subconsciously about what you deserve. And there's a quote I always think of. Whenever I think about these things, whenever I speak to people like yourself or do research on this, and it's that what we seek in our adult relationships is what we didn't have as children. And it goes beyond that in that the relationships we have with our romantic partners, men, women, whoever, will replicate those early parental relationships we have because that is the model. That is the model for how we love ourselves. That is the model for how we let others treat ourselves. And the influence on our adult relationships is just it cannot be forgotten. And I don't think it can be downgraded at all.
随之而来，那就是必须戒掉他们对你的潜移默化和潜意识教导，让你觉得自己配不上什么。有一个名言我总是想起。每当我想到这些事情，每当我与像你这样的人交谈或对此进行研究时，那就是我们在成年关系中寻求的，正是我们小时候没有的东西。它不仅于此，我们在浪漫伴侣、男人、女人或任何人身上建立的关系，将会复制我们早期的父母关系，因为那是模板。那是我们如何爱自己的模板。那是我们如何让其他人对待自己的模板。它对我们成年关系的影响是不可磨灭的。我认为它绝对不能被低估。
And exactly what you said, right, it's, you find that when you are able to detach from that, from that primary caregiver, it becomes a lot easier to stand up for yourself. other relationships because you have already made that decision. You have already, it couldn't hurt you anymore. Your primary relationship with your caregiver or whoever it may be, your guardian, is one of the most fundamental. Everything else is in some ways secondary. I do have a question, though, because there's probably people listening to this who can really identify with you and be like, I actually need to do that. That's my relationship with my mother or my father or my guardian is really similar. Do you have any tips? Like, how did you go about that? And what did you find with some of
就像你刚才说的，对吧，你发现当你能够从那种主要照顾者身上剥离、脱离出来时，在其他关系中为自己挺身而出就会变得容易得多，因为你已经做出了那个决定。你已经——它再也伤害不了你了。你与照顾者或无论它是谁、你的监护人的主要关系是最基础的。其他一切在某种程度上都是次要的。不过我确实有一个问题，因为听这个节目的人中可能有人真的能对你感同身受，并心想：“我其实也需要这么做。我和我母亲、父亲或监护人的关系真的很相似。”你有什么建议吗？比如，你是怎么着手处理这件事的？在这一路上，你发现了一些什么样的关键经验？
those key lessons that you learned along the way? So I'd say for anybody who might be listening and resonating and thinking, wow, this sounds like me. I think I've tolerated abuse from someone who was supposed to protect me and nurture me and love me. Well, when I was in the initial stage of, first of all, believing myself and believing that, yes, this is abuse, I didn't go down the route of confronting the person and being like, I've figured out what you're up to. I know you're trying to break me. Instead, I chose to give myself all the time I needed to mentally detach before I ended up eventually physically moving out. The mental detachment process was the longest and hardest. And I would say that process never entirely really ends. but how I approached that process was I started to really type, this is what I'm grateful for
所以我想对任何可能正在收听、产生共鸣并心想“哇，这听起来太像我了，我想我一直在容忍一个本该保护我、照顾我、爱我的人的虐待”的人说：当我处于最初的阶段时——首先是相信自己，相信“是的，这就是虐待”——我并没有走那种去跟那个人对质、说“我已经弄清楚你在搞什么鬼了，我知道你想击垮我”的路线。相反，我选择给自己所有需要的时间来进行心理上的疏离，直到我最终真正搬出去。心理上的疏离过程是最长、最艰难的。而且我想说，这个过程其实从来没有真正完全结束过。
with YouTube. There are so many people on there who share their own personal accounts about living with a narcissistic parent, living with a controlling parent, living with an abuser. And when I would watch those people's videos, I would notice so many similarities in what I was experiencing. And then I started to believe, oh, this is real and this is not an isolated experience. Okay, now the next step has to be really get into the nucleus of this. Like, why would somebody behave like this? Because now that I know that it's not because of me, I want to understand the background of that person, not to justify or support their behavior, but to understand the scale of what kind of almost monster I'm working with because it feels
但我对待这个过程的方式是，我开始真正地——我很感激YouTube。上面有太多人分享他们自己与自恋型父母、控制型父母、虐待狂共同生活的个人经历。当我观看这些人的视频时，我注意到我所经历的事情有那么多相似之处。然后我开始相信，“哦，这是真的，这不是我一个人的孤立经历。”好的，那么下一步必须是真正深入到这个核心。比如，一个人为什么要这样做？因为既然我知道这不是我的原因，我想了解那个人的背景，不是为了证明或支持他们的行为，而是为了了解我正在打交道的究竟是一个什么样的“怪物”，因为感觉
like the person you love has been taken over by a monster that isn't them. That was how I used to see it as a child. I used to just think that a monster has mounted my mum. And that's why she hates me. Oh my gosh. Right. And so when I would research and see that, okay, this is a cycle of trauma. This is not entirely to do with me. But unfortunately, I am a reflection of my caregiver.
你爱的那个人被一个不属于他们的怪物给占领了。我小时候就是这么看的。我过去常觉得有个怪物骑在我妈妈身上。这就是为什么她讨厌我。天哪。没错。所以当我做研究并发现，好吧，这是一个创伤循环。这并不完全与我有关。但不幸的是，我是我照顾者的镜像。
So they are going to upload their trauma onto me. Well, now I have to start putting myself in self-protection mode because I'm an adult and I need to see that there is a four-year-old child visual of me. and I need to step in and protect that child. So I did everything I could to equip myself with all of the psychological knowledge and support I would need to justify leaving because there were so many times that I almost talked to myself out of it.
所以他们会把他们的创伤转嫁到我身上。好吧，现在我必须开始进入自我保护模式，因为我是一个成年人，我需要看到这里有一个四岁的小女孩形象的我，
And this is why people say that it takes on average, what's the statistic? I think it takes on average, like, is it seven or ten attempts to leave an abuser? Yeah, it's as high as like 20 sometimes. Like, it can take as many times as it takes and it took me quite a while to get over the emotion of feeling guilty. I think guilt is what stops most people from leaving
而我需要介入并保护那个孩子。所以我尽我所能用我需要的所有心理知识和支持来武装自己，以便为离开找到正当理由，因为有很多次我都差点说服自己放弃。
because you feel like now that you've researched and you've got all this information and you've noticed that, oh wow, this person is doing this, not because they are an inherently evil person but because there's something that's gone wrong somewhere down the line for them and they just never made the choice to address it. You start to feel bad.
这就是为什么人们说平均需要——那个统计数据是什么？我想平均需要大约，是7次还是10次尝试才能离开一个虐待者？对，有时甚至高达20次。这可能需要无数次的尝试，而我花了相当长的时间才克服内心的负罪感。我认为负罪感是阻止大多数人离开的原因，
for that person and then you start to justify and then you start to tell yourself, well, they haven't really got anyone else but me. But there's a reason why they haven't got anyone else but you and that's because they have... Oh, yeah, absolutely. They've destroyed all their relationships and you are up next.
因为你会觉得，既然你已经做过研究，掌握了所有这些信息，并且注意到“哦，哇，这个人这样做，并不是因为他们本质上是一个邪恶的人，而是因为他们在人生某个阶段出了问题，而他们从来没有做出选择去解决它”。你开始为那个人感到难过，
So I stopped feeling as guilty and I think something a lot of people are worried about and this is ironically why most women just tolerate really horrible men is because you feel like if you really were to believe yourself and explicitly trust your observations, you feel like you're going to stop being the nice person that you are
然后你开始为他们找借口，然后你开始告诉自己，“好吧，除了我之外，他们真的没有别人了。”但他们除了你之外没有别人是有原因的，那是因为他们已经……哦，对，绝对的。他们已经摧毁了他们所有的关系，而下一个就轮到你了。
because the idea of putting yourself first and leaving somebody right in their tracks when they don't expect it feels as evil as the abuser abusing you. And that's a false equivalence that we create almost as a way that, as a way to kind of create an excuse for yourself to still stay longer. But also because it's really scary to live, life on the other side where you've never known an existence that doesn't involve your primary caregiver's abuse. It feels like it's safer to just stay in the abuse and tell yourself that there's ways to work around it. You can just put your headphones in and ignore the shouting or you can always
所以我不再感到那么内疚了，而且我认为很多人担心的一点——具有讽刺意味的是，这也是为什么大多数女性只是容忍非常可怕的男人的原因——因为你觉得如果你真的相信自己并且明确地信任自己的观察，你会觉得你将不再是一个好人，
just keep on living a double life. And it's not worth it. I think if people were to be told like exactly how many days they have left on this earth, like if we were all walking around, with a floating number above our heads that said how many days we have left on this earth. I think most of us would make the decision quicker to cut ties because it's like living your life on half speed, just like having an abuser in your life who knows that they have access to you because they gave birth to you and because they can. And when it comes to being a woman that dates men and feeling bad about leaving men behind, you have nothing to feel bad about we as women who date men feel guilty about even daring
因为把自己放在第一位并在某人意料之外的时候果断离开他们的想法，感觉和虐待你的虐待狂一样邪恶。这是一种虚假的等同，我们创造它几乎是为了作为一种借口，好让自己能够继续多待一段时间。但这也是因为，在另一边过着一种从未经历过主要照顾者虐待的生活是令人感到非常恐惧的。感觉留在虐待中并告诉自己有办法解决它会更安全。你可以塞上耳机忽略叫喊，或者你也可以
to have a particular standard or having any kind of taste. So it's like going back to my initial point of what you learnt to tolerate as a child will definitely set the tone for what you believe you're deserving of and you have to quite literally go out of your way to make the effort to break that cycle of thinking and it's going to feel unnatural. But just because it feels unnatural doesn't mean that it's wrong. I think that is so difficult. Like what you said were it's like it, like we said, it takes so many times.
一直过着双重生活。这不值得。我想如果有人能被告知他们在这个地球上还剩下多少天——如果我们所有人走在街上时，头上都顶着一个浮动的数字，上面写着我们在地球上还剩下多少天。我想我们大多数人会更快地做出切断联系的决定，因为这就像是以半速过日子，就像身边有一个虐待者，他们知道由于他们生下了你，而且他们有能力，所以他们随时可以接近你。而当谈到作为一个与男人约会的女性并为甩掉男人感到难过时，你没有什么好难得的。我们作为与男人约会的女性，甚至会因为敢于拥有特定的标准或任何品味而感到内疚。所以这就回到了我的最初观点，你在童年时期学会容忍的东西，绝对会为你所认为自己配得上的一切定下基调，你必须不遗余力地去努力打破那种思维循环，这会感觉很不自然。但仅仅因为它感觉很不自然，并不意味着它是错的。我认为这太难了。就像你刚才说的，就像我们说的，离开一个虐待环境需要经历很多次。
to leave an abusive situation. There's so many reasons behind this, right? They hijack our brains. There is a feeling that becomes associated with that person. And it's not just fear, it's not just worry or being scared. There's also the other side of the coin, right? It's how amazing it feels to be loved by them in the moments where they're not harming you, where they're not controlling you.
这背后有很多原因，对吧？他们劫持了我们的大脑。有一种感觉会与那个人联系在一起。这不仅是恐惧，不仅是担忧或害怕。硬币的另一面也是存在的，对吧？就是在他们没有伤害你、没有控制你的时刻，被他们爱着的感觉是多么奇妙。
And something that I think is and often acknowledged is how much that is part of the abusive process. You know, you spoke about financial abuse, emotional abuse, social abuse, cognitive abuse. All of those things are things that are in many ways identical to the abuse that you would experience from a partner. But it's coming from a primary caregiver. You don't get another parent.
我认为有一个经常被忽视的方面，那就是这在多大程度上是虐待过程的一部分。你知道，你谈到了经济虐待、情感虐待、社交虐待、认知虐待。所有这些事情在很多方面都与你从伴侣那里经历的虐待完全相同。但它来自于一个主要的照顾者。你不会再有另一个父母。
You know, you don't get another chance at that parental relationship, which was why I'm sure it would have hurt. so, so much. But on the other side of the coin is I'm sure there are probably moments in which you were like, oh, but maybe this is all right. Maybe I can deal with this. You know, I'm reliant on them for some form of security, some form of comfort. And I think that the other really important point that you raised there, which I think is so, so pertinent to what we're talking about today is how it creates our attachment style, right? Like the relationship you have with your parent, the relationship you have with your primary caregiver, it is going to directly impact how you're going to
你知道，你不会再有第二次获得那种父母关系的机会，这就是为什么我确信这会带来如此巨大的痛苦。但硬币的另一面是，我确信可能有时你会想：“哦，但也许这还可以。也许我能应付这个。”你知道，我在某种程度上依赖他们来获得某种安全感、某种慰藉。我认为你提出的另一个非常重要的观点，对于我们今天讨论的话题非常有针对性的，就是它如何创造了我们的依恋风格，对吧？比如你与父母的关系，你与主要照顾者的关系，它将直接影响你将如何
attach yourselves not just to romantic interests, but to friends, to locations, to cities, to jobs. Because if you've been taught that love is not freely given, you're never going to expect that. And you're never going to welcome that, because that feels like fear to. you. And like I was saying, you know, someone gives you that attention, someone gives you that love, someone gives you that comfort in your previous situations with your primary caregiver, you know what's coming next. There's never love without fear. There's never love without hurt. And so when you grow up, when you become an adult, when you start to make your own family or make your own decisions around who's in your life, there'll be people who are going to offer
依恋——不仅是对浪漫对象的依恋，还有对朋友、对地点、对城市、对工作的依恋。因为如果你被灌输了“爱不是免费给予的”这种观念，你将永远不会期望得到它。你也将永远不会欢迎它，因为那对你来说感觉就像是恐惧。就像我说的，你知道，有人给了你那种关注，有人给了你那种爱，有人给了你那种慰藉，在你以前与主要照顾者的关系中，你知道接下来会发生什么。从来没有没有恐惧的爱。从来没有没有伤害的爱。所以当你长大成人，当你开始组建自己的家庭或者围绕谁在你的生活中做出自己的决定时，会有一些人向你提供
you loving, who are going to really care about you. And there's always that fear, right, that's kind of in the back of your mind, like, when's the other shoe going to drop? Because this is what I've learned to expect. Like, did you find that? I know that we talked about this a little bit about your attachment style. And I do think, like, the dialogue around it is sometimes skewed. And, you know, there's people who are, who will be like, right? Like, they'll be like, I have an avoid an attachment style. And I'm like, uh, really like, I feel like you just had a really bad boyfriend, like a really bad first boyfriend in high school. And I'm like, I avoid an attachment style comes from abuse, it doesn't, you know, it's a pretty strange condition. What did you say?
爱，会真正关心你，而你的脑海深处总是会有那种恐惧，对吧，“另一只靴子什么时候会掉下来？”因为这是我学会去期待的。比如，你发现了吗？我知道我们稍微讨论过你的依恋风格。而且我的确觉得，围绕它的讨论有时是扭曲的。你知道，有些人会这样，他们会说，“我有回避型依恋风格。”而我想，“呃，真的吗？我觉得你只是在高中时交了一个很糟糕的男朋友，一个非常糟糕的初恋男友。”然后我想，“回避型依恋风格来自虐待，它不是……你知道的，这是一种相当奇怪的状况。”你是怎么说的？
I remember you said you're pretty clear about your attachment style and I'd love to hear your explanation of it. So for the most part, I would say that especially while I was still living in the abusive environment and approaching dating as a very early 20-something, my attachment style back then would have been anxious preoccupied and how that shows up is when someone that you are maybe dating or fancy or are attracted to is talking to you whether it's texting you or maybe you're exchanging voice notes and then they go quiet you start to feel like did i do something wrong did i say something wrong does this person no longer like me am i in trouble and why i would make that what could be perceived as very dramatic link would be because as a child, I would get ignored for
我记得你说过你对自己的依恋风格非常清楚，我很想听听你的解释。所以在很大程度上，我想说，特别是在我还生活在虐待环境中、在二十出头时以非常青涩的状态去约那时，我当时的依恋风格会是焦虑痴迷型。它的表现是，当你正在约会、心仪或吸引的某个人在跟你聊天时——不管是给你发短信还是你们在交换语音消息——然后他们突然不说话了，你开始觉得：“我是不是做错了什么？我是不是说错了什么？这个人是不是不再喜欢我了？我是不是惹上麻烦了？”而我为什么会做出这种可能被视为极具戏剧性的联想呢？那是因为在小时候，
like hours to days on end for making mistakes proportional to what a child is capable of doing. And it got me eventually into the conditioning that I deserve to be ignored and that if somebody is ignoring me, it's because I'm a bad person and I've done a bad thing. So growing up into an adult that now dates people, well, when that person would go quiet either because they're probably busy or they don't have anything to say or maybe because they just want to go quiet, I would take it to a very, very far away place and start to feel like I need to seek reassurance from that person. Maybe start asking them, did I do anything wrong? Do you still like me? Why have you gone quiet? Other times I might approach them in a more offensive manner because I feel quite insecure about them.
如果我犯了与小孩子能力相称的错误，我就会被冷落好几个小时甚至好几天。这最终让我形成了一种条件反射：我活该被冷落，如果有人在冷落我，那是因为我是一个坏人，我做了一件坏事。所以长大后成了一个会与人约会的成年人，当那个人安静下来时——可能是因为他们很忙，或者他们没什么可说的，或者可能只是因为他们想安静一会儿——我会把事情推向一个非常非常远的极端，开始觉得我需要从那个人那里寻求安慰。可能会开始问他们：“我是不是做错了什么？你还喜欢我吗？你为什么不说话了？”有时我可能会以更具攻击性的方式接近他们，因为我对他们
going quiet on me and I want to be able to deal the rejection before they get to make me feel rejected. And as I started to get older, I would say now at 28, I think I've shifted on the anxious attachment style sliding scale to more anxious ambivalent. And what I mean by anxious ambivalent is that now when I perceive mixed signals from a guy or hot and cold energy, I essentially feel myself like it's like a higher octave of the ick where I feel no more attraction to that person I kind of feel like my brain just desensitized. Oh yeah. That's like the perfect way to put it.
对我不理不睬感到相当没有安全感，我想在他们让我感到被拒绝之前，先一步表现出拒绝。随着我渐渐长大，我想现在28岁了，我觉得我在焦虑依恋风格的滑动量表上已经转移到了更偏向“焦虑矛盾型”的区间。我所说的焦虑矛盾型是指，现在当我从一个男人那里察觉到混合信号或忽冷忽热的能量时，我基本上会感觉到自己——这就像是“反感”（the ick）的高八度，我不再对那个人感到任何吸引力，我感觉我的大脑只是变得麻木了。哦，对。这就像是完美的表达方式。
Like it is literally a higher version of the ick. Yeah. But it's like your brain compartmentalizing and being like, I don't want to get hurt. Yeah. And the easiest way for me to do that is completely detached. I love how you put that. Yeah. My brain just goes into, my brain's like, well, I mean, he's probably playing a game with you.
就像它字面意义上是“反感”的高阶版。是的。但就像你的大脑在进行自我保护分类，心想：“我不想受到伤害。”是的。而我做到这一点的最简单方法就是彻底抽离。我喜欢你的这种说法。是的。我的大脑直接进入了——我的大脑会想：“好吧，这意味着他可能在跟你玩心理游戏。”
So whatever nice butterflies you were feeling last Tuesday, the butterflies are dead now. And we can go find something else to do. Like, I find it so easy to detach from men. And I'm not even saying it to brag and be like, yeah, I'm scissors hands up in this club. No, I mean, like, I can just chalk it to the game and be like, well, this person probably doesn't like me anymore. So if I most times end up being wrong in my perception of that person's silence and they come back and say something like, oh my God, sorry I disappeared for a while. I was handling things with my parents or sorry I was away. I was busy at work.
所以无论你上周二感受到了多么美好的心动感觉，那些心动现在都已经死掉了。我们可以去找别的事做。比如，我觉得从男人身上抽离出来是如此容易。我这么说甚至不是为了吹牛，好显得“哼，我在情场上可是个快刀手”。不，我的意思是，我可以把这归咎于逢场作戏，然后想：“好吧，这个人可能不再喜欢我了。”所以如果我最终对那个人的沉默的感知在大多数时候是错的，而他们又回过头来说类似这样的话：“哦，天哪，对不起，我消失了一段时间。我一直在处理我父母的事情，”或者“对不起，我不在。我工作很忙，”
Then it almost feels like kind of refreshing at their back. It's like, oh, you're back again. Hey friend. Like I don't even bother with where were you? I'm not interested in you anymore. You disappeared on me. It's like, okay, this person's still around. Well, let's see how it goes.
那么当他们回来时，几乎会感觉有点耳目一新。就像是：“哦，你又回来了。嘿，朋友。”我甚至懒得去追问“你当时去哪儿了？”我对你已经不感兴趣了。你从我面前消失了。这就像是：“好吧，这个人还在。嗯，让我们看看情况会怎样。”
Like, I'm in a very, let's see how it goes place in life. And, you know, there are people who are ambivalently attached and sort of towards the more colder described side of the attachment spectrum where, you know, it's mainly guys who are like that where they just don't even communicate anything to you. They just change their energy without updating you. And you just feel a bit lost. Like, oh, what's going on here? I'm pretty sure this guy told me that he wanted to, like, fly me out somewhere. Like, I'm sure you liked me. Like, I'm pretty sure you were flirting with me.
就像我处于生活中的“让我们看看情况会怎样”的阶段。而且，你知道，有些人是矛盾型依恋，并且偏向于依恋光谱中比较冷淡的那一端——你知道，基本上是那种根本不跟你沟通任何事情的男人，他们只是在不通知你的情况下改变自己的能量。然后你就会觉得有点迷茫，“哦，这里到底怎么了？我挺确信这家伙之前告诉我他想带我飞去某地玩呢。我觉得你应该挺喜欢我的。我挺确信你之前在跟我调情来着。”
And now I've not heard from you in two weeks. Like what happened here? Yeah. And for me, right? Like, that switch was very swift. And I'm not sure about that. And for me, when guys do that, because the thing is, no matter how hard you've worked on yourself,
“而现在我已经两周没听到你的消息了。这到底是怎么回事？”是的。而对我来说，对吧？那种转变是非常迅速的。我不确定……对我来说，当男人这样做时——因为事实是，无论你在自己身上付出了多大的努力，
no matter how pretty you are, smart you are, funny you are, academically achieved you are, that is not going to stop a guy from acting funny towards you because you don't even know why a guy is attracted to you, especially if his intentions are to get supply from you. And what I mean by supply is like an ego boost or they just love the feeling of getting your attention because at some point they perceived you as unattainable. And now that they have your attention, you don't even see the value in your attention
无论你有多漂亮、多聪明、多有趣、学业成就多高，那都无法阻止一个男人对你表现得古怪，因为你甚至不知道一个男人为什么会被你吸引，尤其是当他的意图是从你这里获得“供给”时。我所说的供给就像是自我价值的提升，或者他们就是喜欢获得你关注的感觉，因为在某个时刻他们认为你是高不可攀的。而现在他们得到了你的关注，你甚至看不到自己关注的价值，
because you don't view yourself in that way and you don't view other people in that way. But for a lot of these guys who might approach you and start acting very sort of like dismissive avoidant where it almost feels as though if you were to really. raise a concern, they flip it back at you and you feel like a problem for having a concern. For me, I find that trigger in because it just reminds me of, again, being in that dynamic with my primary caregiver and raising a concern and just being dismissed or being told that I'm making a big deal or just go shut up and go play with a toy or something, like just being dismissed. And when men make me feel dismissed, that's an instant disqualification.
因为你并不是那样看待自己，你也不是那样看待其他人。但对于许多可能接近你并开始表现得非常疏离、回避的男人来说，这感觉几乎就像是如果你真的提出一个担忧，他们会把问题反推给你，让你觉得自己因为有了担忧而成了问题。对我和我来说，这会触发那种创伤，因为它只是让我想起了——再次回到与主要照顾者的那种互动中——提出了一个担忧却被驳回，或者被告知我在小题大做，或者只是被叫去“闭嘴去跟玩具玩”之类的，就是那种被忽视的感觉。而当男人让我感到被忽视时，那是瞬间被取消资格。
Like, I don't even bother with trying to salvage that because it's not salvageable. Yeah, no second chances. Honestly, like, and you've, I feel like I, you might be at the stage as well where I'm like, I've learnt my lessons from this. I don't need to learn that lesson again. I don't need to be dismissed again. Like, you're 28 years old. And I feel like you're on this really healthy, almost like journey towards a secure attachment.
就像我甚至懒得去试图挽救它，因为那是无法挽救的。是的，没有第二次机会。老实说，而且你——我觉得我，你可能也到了这个阶段，我心想：“我已经从中学到了教训。我不需要再学一遍那个教训。我不需要再次被忽视。”你看，你28岁了。我觉得你正处于一段非常健康的、几乎是朝着安全型依恋迈进的旅程中。
Like, that's what I'm hearing. I want to believe so. That's the goal. Because the other day, I took one of those attachment. there's these like attachment style tests you can take on the internet. Dara, don't do those online. Is it? Are they like, are they not good?
这就是我听到的。我想相信是这样。这就是目标。因为前几天，我做了一个依恋测试——互联网上有那种你可以做的依恋风格测试。切德拉，别在网上做那些。是吗？它们难道不好吗？
No, just talk to me, honestly. Don't do the online ones. I'm going to tell, oh my God, the online ones are a scam. I'm telling you this right now. But what did you tell you? You heard it here first, folks. Yeah, it's endorsed. It's a scam.
不，老实说，跟我聊聊就行了。别去做网上的那些测试。我要告诉你——天哪，网上的那些测试都是骗局。我现在就告诉你。但它对你说了什么？你在这里听到了，各位。对，这是有背书的。是个骗局。
Yeah, but what did it tell you? Did it say you were secure? Well, it told me our secure, but I was like, I'm not going to believe that because I'm not. I don't want to just believe that I'm secure and not do any work on myself. So I'm going to tell myself I'm still anxious, ambivalent and I'm okay with that because the ambivalence has saved me way more than the preoccupied version of me has done. I feel like that is, that's on your way to secure, right? But then I think it's more of a personal thing about you where you're like, I cannot
对，但它对你说了什么？它说你是安全型吗？好吧，它确实说我是安全型的，但我当时想：“我才不会相信那个，因为我根本不是。”我不想仅仅相信自己是安全型的，却不在自己身上做任何努力。所以我要告诉自己，我仍然是焦虑矛盾型的，我对这一点感到满意，因为这种矛盾性比我过去那种痴迷焦虑的版本拯救了我更多。我觉得这简直是——你在通往安全型的路上，对吧？但我觉得这更多是关于你个人的事情，你会心想：“我不能”
stop working on myself because you are so cognizant of what happened in your childhood. And because you do kind of carry this added weight, this added emotional weight and added responsibility. because I feel like the thing that is the reason why you are able to spread so much truth is because you're committed to working on yourself and because you are able to see that link. So I think what you're saying is like, okay, I can't believe that I'm secure because that means that I have to stop working on myself and that's not something that I'll ever have to stop doing. That's something that is a continual process and I know how easy it will be to slide back.
停止对自我的剖析，因为你对童年发生的种种有着深刻的认知。正因为你承载了这种额外的负担、额外的情感负担以及额外的责任。因为我觉得，你之所以能够传播如此多的真理，原因就在于你致力于剖析自我，并且你能够看到这其中的联系。所以我觉得你的意思是，好吧，我不敢相信我是安全的，因为那意味着我必须停止剖析自我，而这并不是一件我会停止去做的事。这是一个持续的过程，而且我很清楚自己有多容易倒退回过去。
I just, I just think it's so interesting. I would believe that it tells you that you're secure, but it's interesting that you don't believe it, that you're like, no. Yeah, the thing is, because it asks me, like, when I think about some of the questions it would ask, it would be like, do you feel okay with not hearing from anyone? And one time I think I ticked, yes, because I like to be on my own for a while,
我只是，我只是觉得这太有趣了。我会认为这说明你是安全的，但有趣的是你并不相信这一点，你觉得“不”。是的，事情是这样的，因为它问我，当我想象它可能会问的一些问题时，它会问，对于长时间听不到任何人的消息，你感觉还好吗？有一次我想我勾选了“是”，因为我喜欢一个人待一会儿，
and in theory, I'm okay with not being surrounded by attention. Or it will ask you things like... Because I'm an introvert. Yeah, or the prompts would be like, do you feel rejected if you don't hear from someone you care about? Like questions like that. And sometimes I might answer, yes, sometimes my answer no.
而且理论上，我对于不被关注所包围感到没问题。或者它会问你一些诸如……因为我是个内向的人。是的，或者提示会是，如果你在乎的人没有联系你，你会觉得被拒绝吗？诸如此类的问题。有时我可能会回答“是”，有时我会回答“否”。
So because my answers were kind of 50-50, it kind of was like, you seem secure. The thing is, right, I feel like the reason why I reject the, yeah, the reason why I reject the computer telling me that I'm secure is because I still catch myself having human moments
所以因为我的答案差不多各占一半，它就觉得，你看起来很安全。问题是，我觉得我拒绝，是的，我拒绝电脑告诉我我很安全的原因是，我仍然发现自己会有一些人性的时刻，
where I'm like, this don't feel secure. Like, I do not feel secure with this man. And I know that it's not because I'm in, secure is because this man has not created a secure dynamic with me. He has not nurtured this. He has not watered this plant. Yes. So I'm not going to just because I'm being told that I'm secure, just like ignore my needs, like just because you're secure doesn't mean you're not going to have needs. And also another thing that I learned is that you can be a person that has a secure attachment style, but there's still like an underlying secondary attachment style that's like waiting,
那时我会想，这感觉一点也不安全。比如，我对这个男人一点安全感也没有。我知道这不是因为我不安全，而是因为这个男人没有跟我建立起一种安全互动。他没有培养这个。他没有给这株植物浇水。是的。所以，我不会仅仅因为别人告诉我我很安全，就忽视自己的需求，就像你觉得安全并不意味着你不会有需求。另外，我还学到的一点是，你可能是一个拥有安全型依恋风格的人，但底下仍然隐藏着一种次要的依恋风格，
simmering underneath where if you're triggered, if you're around somebody who is very rejecting of you who blows hot and cold, that will activate the attachment style that you have healed from. So in my case, if I'm around a guy who is very, very hot and cold, ambivalent, laying it on heavy, then just disappearing, that will provoke me to feel somewhere between, like, anxious, preoccupied, where I'm preoccupied about, you know, trying to figure out what's going on here, but also ambivalent enough to be like, I am liking this guy less and less now. I don't give a fuck. And it could be argued that, because, you know, I go back and forth with my therapist about this,
在暗中酝酿，如果你被触发了，如果你和某个对你非常排斥、忽冷忽热的人在一起，那就会激活你已经治愈的依恋风格。所以在我的情况下，如果我和一个非常、非常忽冷忽热、矛盾纠结、表现得极其热情随后又突然消失的男人在一起，那就会促使我产生介于焦虑与全神贯注之间的感觉，我会全神贯注于弄清楚这里到底发生了什么，但同时也矛盾到觉得，我现在越来越不喜欢这家伙了。我他妈才不在乎呢。而且有人可能会说，因为，你知道的，我和我的治疗师来回讨论过这件事，
where I'm trying to not be that person who is like so cynical and closed off from love where I don't really give anything or even give myself a chance to feel the butterflies and feel goofy in love. And the thing is I get it. But at the same time, I'm not in a hurry to just like relax into a love that hasn't been securely built. Like everything from the foundations through to the windows, through to the notches on the doors, Everything needs to be in place before I relax into that because I just don't think men are okay.
我试图不让自己成为那种愤世嫉俗、对爱关闭心扉的人，不肯付出任何东西，甚至不给自己一个去感受小鹿乱撞和在爱里傻里傻气的机会。问题是我懂。但与此同时，对于那种还没有建立在安全基础上的爱，我并不急于放松身心去接受。就像从地基到窗户，再到门上的刻痕，所有的一切都需要到位，然后我才会放松下来去享受，因为我只是觉得男人不太对劲。
And if you're someone that dates men, you can't afford to just relax and trust into them loving you without you having seen that this is somebody who does their own work on their own accord without any external prompt from you. Once I come across a person like that, which I've come across in my friendships with men, I can be so relaxed and feel so loved around men. Like I have such loving friendships with the men in my life that I do know that it's, possible to find men that are working on themselves. But just because it's possible doesn't mean that I'm going to project that possibility onto every man that I'm attracted to because you can be attracted to someone and you can get on really well with them. But for some reason, once things get to a more serious place and you notice that they're not giving you the energy that you perceived that you fell in love with, you have to believe what you're perceiving because most people go off
如果你是一个和男人约会的人，你可承受不起在完全没看到对方是在没有任何外部催促的情况下靠自己做出改变的情况下，就放松下来去相信他们爱着你。一旦我遇到这样的人，我在与男人的友谊中遇到过，我就可以在男人面前感到无比放松和被爱。就像我和生命中的男人们有着非常深厚的友谊，我知道寻找那些在努力完善自我的男人是有可能的。但这并不意味着我会把这种可能性投射到我被吸引的每个男人身上，因为你可以被某人吸引，也可以和他们相处得很好。但出于某种原因，一旦事情变得更加严肃，你发现他们没有给你那种你以为你与之坠入爱河的能量，你就必须相信你的感知，因为大多数人都是基于
of the version of the man that they met two years ago. But I'm always, I'm always big on who is he right now that's the man you need to make a decision on who is he right now not who he was two years ago when he was giving you vibes and giving you hugs and making you feel good who is he right now how do you feel right now and I totally agree it's actually so interesting that you talk about almost being like
两年前遇到的那个男人的版本来做判断。但我一直以来，我一直非常看重的是：他现在是谁？这才是你需要做出决定的那个男人——他现在是谁，而不是两年前他给你提供情绪价值、给你拥抱、让你感觉良好的那个他。他现在是谁？你现在的感觉如何？我完全同意，其实很有趣的是，你谈到几乎像是
I do want to fall in love right like that is something that I want I want that lovey feeling once you are able to it's not really like a vetting system I wouldn't call it a vetting system but it's almost like for a lack of a better word it's like I think
我确实想坠入爱河，对吧——这确实是我想要的，我想要那种恋爱的感觉。一旦你能够，这其实不完全是一个审查系统，我不会称之为审查系统，但它几乎就像是，用找不到更好词的话来说，就像是，我觉得
it's a better system exactly because it's like I actually I think that's something Quality control Quality control Oh man Quality control Men need to go through a few rounds of that
这确实是一个更好的系统，因为这就像，实际上，我觉得这是某种质量控制。质量控制。天哪。质量控制。男人需要经历几轮这个过程。
They've got to meet the friends Oh my God And one extra one for safety Yes Literally literally I never go to a man's place For the first like two months that I'm seeing But the thing that I've found
他们得去见见朋友。天哪。为了安全起见还得再加一个。是的。真的，真的。在我见一个男人的前两个月左右，我绝不会去他的住所。但我发现的事情是，
is that like I think at the end of last year, and tell me if you felt this at some point in your life as well, I had my heartbroken by someone who treated me terribly, and I went to the absolute opposite end of the deepest steps of cynical, where I was like, I am completely determined that I can be alone for the rest of my life, and any form of love is going to hurt me. And it was really sad, because I am someone who wants to be loved, and I know you're someone who wants to be loved as well. it's a human instinct to want that for ourselves. But I was so like protective of myself.
就像去年年底的时候，如果你在生命的某个阶段也有过这种感受，请告诉我，我曾被一个对我极度恶劣的人伤透了心，我走向了愤世嫉俗最深处的极端，当时我觉得，我完全下定决心这辈子都可以一个人过，任何形式的爱都会伤害我。这真的很让人难过，因为我是一个渴望被爱的人，我也知道你是一个渴望被爱的人。渴望为自己争取这一点是人类的本能。但我当时对自己的保护意识太强了。
And it was almost like a barrier that was established out of fear to be like, I don't want to be hurt. I don't want someone to break down this barrier. I don't want someone to put me through this pain again. And it was something I had to unlearn, which was like, how can I, I don't need men, but I want them. And I know that like partnership is a beautiful thing. That's the important sentence though. Yeah, you think so? I don't want men.
这几乎就像是为了害怕受伤而建立起的一道屏障，好像在说：我不想受伤，我不想让任何人打破这道屏障，我不想让任何人让我再次经历这种痛苦。这是我不得不戒掉的一个想法，那就是：我不需要男人，但我想要他们。而且我知道伴侣关系是一件美好的事情。不过，这才是最重要的一句。是的，你觉得呢？我不需要男人。
I don't need men, but I want them. Yeah, because you know what? Even the cynicism you're referring to, I believe personally that anybody who has allowed their self to go through the stages of separating from an abuser will inevitably at some point be met with that stage of cynicism. And I do think that's part of the healing process because your body and your mind,
我不需要男人，但我想拥有他们。是的，因为你知道吗？甚至连你提到的那种愤世嫉俗，我个人认为，任何允许自己经历与虐待狂决裂阶段的人，在某个时刻都不可避免地会遇到愤世嫉俗的阶段。我认为这也是治愈过程的一部分，因为你的身体和心灵，
just your whole being needs to learn and experience what it's like to be independent. and to thrive on your own. But I think the next stage after cynicism is kind of like still acknowledging that, you know, men might not be the source of the love that you deserve, but it doesn't mean that you're never going to find love in this world. And in my case, it's kind of like that's where I learned how to lean into my community. And that was where I learned how, and part of why I feel so empowered to even have, standards when it comes to men is because of my cynicism where it's like, well, I'm so chilled
你的整个存在都需要学习和体验独立是什么感觉，以及如何靠自己蓬勃发展。但我认为愤世嫉俗之后的下一个阶段有点像是，仍然承认，你知道的，男人可能不是你应得的爱的源泉，但这并不意味着你永远在这个世界上找不到爱。在我的情况下，这就有点像我学会了如何依靠我的社群。这也是我学会了的，而且我之所以觉得有底气在面对男人时设立标准，部分原因正是因为我的愤世嫉俗，这就好比，在我的愤世嫉俗中我是如此从容，
out in my cynicism that I'm open to being surprised. This is an invitation for you to surprise me. I'm not saying that men can't ever be great. I'm saying except the challenge then. I love that. Like, I'm open to being surprised. But until that happens, I will remain on my frequency of healthy cynicism where I'm not going to be carried away by the fluttery feelings of a man liking me, I do think that if you're somebody that is very, very empathetic, hypersensitive, easily, um, easily absorb absorbing of other people's like pain and wounds, you do need to have like a cynic, like a cynical kind of sheet of film. It's like an invisible sheet of film that you can just put on temporarily, but remember to take it off. Like, you don't have
以至于我随时准备好接受惊喜。这是邀请你来给我惊喜。我并不是说男人永远不会变好。我是说，那就接受这个挑战吧。我喜欢这样。就像，我随时准备好接受惊喜。但在那之前，我将保持我那健康的愤世嫉俗的频率，我不会被一个男人喜欢我时那种小鹿乱撞的感觉冲昏头脑。我确实认为，如果你是一个非常、非常感性、高度敏感、很容易、嗯，很容易吸收别人的痛苦和创伤的人，你确实需要有一层愤世嫉俗的薄膜。就像一层看不见的薄膜，你可以暂时把它戴上，但记得要脱下来。就像，你不需要
to live your whole life in a cynical place, but anybody who has been around draining, narcissistic people knows that when you come across that grandiose eccentricity in a lot of men, you do have to be a bit cynical. And it's not a bad thing. It doesn't mean that you're this person that's like, you know, you're so negative and you can't find joy in anything anymore. It's like, no, I want to see what this person is about. Oh, yeah.
把一辈子都活在愤世嫉俗的状态中，但任何跟那些消耗能量的自恋狂接触过的人都知道，当你遇到许多男人身上那种宏大而古怪的性格时，你确实必须变得有点愤世嫉俗。这并不是一件坏事。这并不意味着你是个这样的人，你知道的，你太消极了，再也无法在任何事物中找到快乐。这更像是：不，我想看看这人到底是什么货色。哦，是的。
Yeah. And I think women deserve to be cynical in a world that like spins against them in a world where men continue to use us. Like, I think cynicism is a much better place to land than all women being vengeful. And I love what you said before about, and I honestly am like waiting till we're done to go and journal this. But like, you're allowed to be surprised. I had not thought about that. Like, you're allowed to be surprised.
是的。而且我认为女性在一个处处与她们作对的世界里、在一个男人继续剥削我们的世界里，有资格变得愤世嫉俗。我觉得，相比于所有女性都变得满怀报复心，愤世嫉俗是一个好得多的归宿。我非常喜欢你刚才说的话，而且老实说，我恨不得等我们录完就去写日记：你可以期待惊喜。我之前从没想过这一点。就像，你可以期待惊喜。
And I've had these conversations with friends of mine. So my friends, my closest friends are all in relationships with men that I think are amazing people, who I would actually count as friends. friends. But I was having this conversation. We've talked about this before, but I was having this conversation with my friend and they were like, you're in your misandry. You're on your man hating error. And you've got to get through it. And I was like, and I remember being like, okay, I'm kind of offended. And she said to me, she was like, I cannot wait till the moment where I get to meet the love of your life. And I was like, why? Why? Why can't you wait? Like, obviously, like, that would be exciting. But I was like, I would much rather be single until I was 35. And,
我和我的朋友们聊过这些。所以我的朋友们，我最要好的朋友们都处在恋爱关系中，他们的伴侣在我看来都是了不起的人，我甚至把他们当朋友。但我在进行这种交谈。我们以前讨论过这个，但我当时正和我的朋友聊起这事，他们说：“你正处于厌男情结中。你正处于厌男期。你得挺过去。”我就觉得，我记得当时觉得有点被冒犯。她对我说：“我简直等不及要见你生命中的挚爱了。”我就说：“为什么？为什么？你为什么等不及？当然，这会很让人激动。”但我当时觉得，我宁愿单身到35岁，然后
then find someone who really suited me. And like, this is the thing to Dara, like, we are pretty impressive, independent, powerful women. We are self-starters. Yes, we are. And that's facts. It is. Yeah. Facts. We're educated. We're incredibly, like, we have an impact. And that's an amazing privilege, right? But it also means that when I look around at people who could potentially add to that, like, there's not much that I couldn't do for myself. And, And there's not much that I couldn't provide to myself. So I feel like when you were talking about that analogy of making sure that all the hinges on the door, right, the windows, like the secure foundation of a relationship, I would much
再找一个真正适合我的人。达拉，事情就是这样，我们都是相当了不起、独立且有力量的女性。我们都是靠自己取得成就的人。没错，我们是。这是事实。确实如此。是的。事实。我们受过良好教育。我们非常有，影响力。这是一种惊人的特权，对吧？但这也意味着，当我环顾四周寻找那些可能为这种生活增添价值的人时，其实没有什么是靠我自己做不到的，而且也没有什么是我无法提供给自己的。所以我觉得，当你谈到那个比喻，确保门上的所有合页、窗户以及关系的稳固地基都建好时，我宁愿
rather find that at 35 and spend the next like decade or less of my life being alone, then think that I found that now, you know, end up at 35 and realize that I was completely misguided. And, you know, my house is falling down and I've got to rebuild. I just think it's like it's worth the way. it's worth the sacrifice and it's not even a sacrifice right like our relationship with our self is the most important i was going to say sometimes you can't even you can't even rebuild a collapsed house you end up having to just relocate and uproot your life all over again i see this happened to women time and time again where you know they got married to the guy that gave them
在35岁时找到这一切，然后花接下来十年或更少的时间独自生活，也不愿以为自己现在找到了，你知道的，结果到了35岁才发现自己完全被误导了，你知道的，我的房子倒塌了，我还得重新建。我只是觉得这绝对值得等待。这值得做出牺牲，而且这甚至都算不上牺牲，对吧？我们与自己的关系才是最重要的。我本来想说，有时候你甚至都无法重建一栋倒塌的房子，你最后只能搬迁，把生活连根拔起重新开始。我一次又一次地看到这种事发生在女性身上，你知道的，她们嫁给了那个带给她们
the butterflies and then they got married and then they realized that they were love bombed essentially and now they're spending five years in a divorce process and you know they're now left with this what was once a house that had, you know, the door hinges were talking about and the foundation, you realise all of it is broken and doesn't even work. You can't, there is not even any resale value to it. You just got to abandon that thing and just start again and move elsewhere. And what you were saying about, the joke your friend made about you being in a misandry era. So for those who are listening and might be wondering, what does misandry mean? Misandry is a term that was coined to essentially mean hating men. But what's really interesting
心跳感觉的男人，然后结了婚，接着才意识到她们本质上是被“情感轰炸”了，现在她们花了五年时间在搞离婚程序，你知道的，她们现在留下的这个房子曾经拥有，你知道的，我们刚才讨论的门合页和地基，结果发现这一切都破碎了，根本不管用。你甚至都无法转手变现。你只能放弃那玩意儿，重新开始，搬到别的地方去。至于你刚才说的，你朋友开玩笑说你处于厌男期。所以对于正在收听、可能在想“厌男”是什么意思的听众来说，厌男是一个创造出来的词，本质上意味着厌恶男性。但非常有趣的是，
is that I get called a misandrist all the time, mainly from men, surprisingly from women too, and usually men call me... From women? Yeah, I get women telling me that I'm a misandrist and that I hate men, because obviously men conflate accountability with hate, but also because the idea that a woman would be consistent in her disgust for men must mean that she hates them and it must mean she's a bad person, because the misandry label is about your morality. Whereas when a man is called misogynistic, it's not because he's a good or bad person,
我一直被称为厌男者，主要是男人这样叫我，出人意料的是也有女人这么叫，而且通常男人会称我……来自女人？对，有女人告诉我我是厌男者，说我厌恶男人，因为显然男人把承担责任和仇恨混为一谈，而且也是因为，一个女人如果对男人的厌恶始终如一，那一定意味着她恨他们，也一定意味着她是个坏人，因为“厌男”这个标签是针对你的道德评判。然而当一个男人被称为厌女时，并不是因为他是好人还是坏人，
just because he just like has that particular line of thinking. So in my case, what I find interesting is that I'm yet to meet someone that can just quickly, very quickly, just show me where and how men are affected by misogyny in a way that is material, societal and physical. Like nobody can show me how men are marginalized because of misogyny. The violence that women experience across the world at the hands of violence. men, it's determined by the societies that you live in and how men enable other men to continue. So, yes, if men want better stories told about them, one, they should behave better.
只是因为他刚好有那种特定的思维方式。所以在我的情况下，我觉得有趣的是，我还没遇到一个人能够迅速地、非常迅速地向我展示男人是如何受到厌女症影响的，并且这种影响是实质性的、社会的和身体的。没有人能向我展示男人是如何因为厌女症而被边缘化的。全世界女性在男人手下遭受的暴力，是由你所生活的社会以及男人如何纵容其他男人继续作恶来决定的。所以，是的，如果男人希望世人对他们有更好的评价，第一，他们应该表现得更好。
And two, you don't really get to push someone and tell them where to fall. They see you having boundaries as violence towards them. They see you not wanting to sleep with them as hate speech. Oh my God, that's literally, I was going to say, like, That's exactly what that reminded me of. It's like, okay, so I'm in my man-hating error, air quotes there, as my friend described it. And if she's listening to this, I do love you. You're just will misguarded.
第二，你真的没有资格去逼迫别人并规定他们该如何反应。他们把你的设立边界视为对他们的暴力。他们把你不愿意跟他们发生性关系视为仇恨言论。天哪，这简直是，我正要说，这太像了，这正是我想到的。这就好比，好吧，所以我正处于我的“厌男期”（这里加上引号），就像我朋友形容的那样。如果她在听这个，我是真的很爱你。你只是被误导了。
But like, I'm in my man-hating era, right? What's the worst that's going to happen to someone because of that? You know, I'm not going to have sex with you. I'm not going to, like, talk to you. I'm not going to give you my attention and my love. Do you know what it makes you realize as a man is how much I actually give to you? And what happens to you when I take a. it away. That is the worst consequence that you're going to realize. And I hope that it's a good
但就像，我正处于我的厌男期，对吧？因为这个，别人会遭遇的最糟糕的事情是什么？你知道的，我不会跟你发生性关系。我不会，你知道的，跟你说话。我不会把我的注意力和爱给你。你知道作为一个男人，这会让你意识到，我实际上给了你多少吗？当我把这一切收回时，你会遭遇什么。这是你会意识到的最糟糕的后果。我希望这是一个好
lesson, right, to realize that I'm actually a very valuable, I'm a valuable person. And you might notice what I'm not there, but most of the time, you probably won't. And the opposite, like, when you think about the misogyny that's lodged against women, it's a lot more tangible. It's a lot more tangible than you're not getting to have sex with me. And most of the rebuttals I get from people, whether it's men or women, you know, against my ideologies trying to imply that me not having the time of day for men is harmful towards them. All these ideologies end in. Women are just supposed to give men more access to our body so that they can stop feeling bad about themselves. And that I was telling you about
教训，对吧，让你意识到我其实是一个非常有价值的人。当我不在这儿时，你可能会注意到，但大多数时候，你可能不会。与此相反，比如说，当你想到强加给女性的厌女症时，它要切实得多。它比你无法跟我发生性关系要切实得多。我从人们那里得到的绝大多数反驳，无论是男人还是女人，你知道的，反对我的意识形态，试图暗示我懒得搭理男人对他们是有害的。所有这些意识形态最终都落脚于：女人就应该给男人更多接触我们身体的权限，这样他们就能停止对自己的负面情绪。这就是我之前跟你说过的
that email I got the other day from this person, I am not, I would not. I would not say that I'm a highly controversial person, right? Like, yet this person, and even if I was, I still didn't deserve this. I think that I am sometimes cautious about sharing a lot about my personal life. Like, I think that people who listen to me understand, like, the basic narrative of the last three years of my life, right? But they don't understand, they don't know me. They don't know who I am. And this person sent me, this guy sent me this email. And it was a essentially being like, I hate you. I think that you are the worst person in the world. You are the reason why I, this man I've never met, can't get a date. You're the reason that women are so misguided in society.
我前几天收到这个人的电邮，我不会，我绝对不会说自己是一个极具争议的人，对吧？然而这个人，就算我真的是，我也不该受到这种对待。我觉得有时我对分享自己的私生活非常谨慎。就像，我认为听我节目的人能理解，比如我过去三年人生的基本情况，对吧？但他们并不理解，他们不了解我。他们不知道我是谁。这个人发给我，这个家伙给我发了这封电邮。内容大体上就是说，我恨你。我觉得你是世界上最糟糕的人。你就是我——这个我从未谋面的男人——找不到女朋友的原因。你就是社会上女性被严重误导的原因。
And it was almost 800,000 words long. And I had to receive that email. I'm just going to say, I have never sent anyone, like anyone, something that hateful, that they had to read and they had to remember. And I was like, I made one, you know, statement about how I'm setting boundaries for myself and about how I'm going to date the right people in 2023. And you equated that with me absolutely ruining your life. Well, doesn't that tell you then that like men are the lonely ones, men are the real ones who have got a ticking time bomb over their heads. Anything that they've projected onto us is actually their reality. And those projections include the idea that as a woman, you're going to end up on your own
而且那篇东西差不多有八十万字长。我还不得不去读那封电邮。我只想说，我从来没有给任何人，任何人发过那样充满仇恨的内容，让他们不得不去读、不得不去记住。当时我在想，我不过是发表了一个声明，关于我如何为自己设定界限，以及我如何在2023年寻找对的人约会。而你却把这等同于我彻底毁了你的人生。好吧，这难道不说明男人才是孤独的那一方，男人才是真正头上悬着定时炸弹的人吗？他们投射到我们身上的任何东西，其实正是他们自己的现实。而这些投射包括这样一种观念：作为一个女人，你最终会落得孤身一人
if you don't give in to a man's dominion and as a woman you're going to be super miserable if you don't marry a man and oh my goodness you're single, I bet you're secretly lonely when actually the reality is most men can't live without the physical touch and validation of a woman.
如果你不向男人的统治屈服的话；作为一个女人，如果你不嫁给男人，你就会超级痛苦；哦天哪，你是单身的，我敢打赌你内心其实很孤独。但实际上，现实是大多数男人都离不开女性的身体触碰和认可。
That's why a man from across the world has told you that you have ruined his life by you just hypothetically expressing that you want to date better people. And in my case, I get actual incels commenting on my Instagram posts saying bring back Andrew Tate, we need more Andrew Tate's in this world. And that to me is insane.
这就是为什么一个远在世界另一端的男人会告诉你，仅仅因为你假设性地表达了你想和更好的人约会，你就毁了他的人生。而在我的情况下，我的Instagram帖子下经常有真正的incel（非自愿独身者）评论，说让安德鲁·泰特（Andrew Tate）回归，我们需要更多像安德鲁·泰特这样的人。对我来说，这太疯狂了。
Like Andrew Tate has just been arrested on suspicion of sex trafficking women. And even outside of him being arrested on such heavy suspicions, he's been making content for years where he has amassed and assembled a physical community of men who have all been taught to do the lover boy method, which is what Andrew Tate explains verbatim on his own website, how to essentially coerce a woman into sexually working for you, which to me is deplorable. And when men see me making content encouraging women to just like,
就像安德鲁·泰特刚刚因涉嫌贩卖妇女而被捕一样。抛开他因涉嫌如此严重的罪名被捕不谈，多年来他一直在制作内容，聚集并组建了一个由男性组成的实体社群，他们都被灌输并学习了“情圣诱拐法”（lover boy method）。这就是安德鲁·泰特在他自己的网站上逐字解释的内容，即如何本质上强迫女性为你进行性工作，这在我看来是令人发指的。当男人们看到我制作鼓励女性的内容时——
you know, that whole thing men say where they're like, well, since you're having such a hard time with men, then date better men. Well, I'm here trying to encourage women to date better men. And then men are being like, actually we need more Andrew Tates. Actually, I think you need to die. Oh my God, I hate that they say that to you.
你知道，男人经常说的那种鬼话，他们会说，既然你和男人相处得这么艰难，那就去和更好的男人约会呗。好吧，我现在就在这里鼓励女性去和更好的男人约会。然后男人们却说，其实我们需要更多的安德鲁·泰特。其实，我觉得你应该去死。哦天哪，我恨他们对你说这种话。
But like the common thing of like not all men. And then when you're like, okay, so not all men, let's find the men that are good. You know, like I said, you don't need. But you might want. And they're like, you're absolutely misguided. You're absolutely wrong. It doesn't work both ways. Like you can't have it both ways.
但就像那种“并非所有男人”的常见论调。然后当你说，好吧，既然不是所有男人，那我们就去找好男人吧。你知道的，就像我说的，你不需要。但你可能会想要。而他们却说，你完全被误导了。你完全错了。事情不是双向的。就像你不能鱼和熊掌兼得一样。
You can't make these generalized sweeps in the positive and the negative. That it's not all men. But then when you talk about like wanting. to teaching women and teaching folks to date better people, they're like, well, why do you need to do this? Well, isn't it ironic that men will not all men you to death until they have a daughter, then they're going to teach their daughter, stay away from boys, stay away from men, and I'm going to get a shotgun.
你不能一方面做出这些正面和负面的泛泛而谈，说什么“并非所有男人”。但另一方面，当你谈到想要引导女性和人们去和更好的人约会时，他们却说，好吧，你为什么非得这么做？好吧，这不是很讽刺吗？男人们会不停地对你使用“并非所有男人”这一招，直到他们有了女儿，然后他们就会教导女儿，离男孩远点，离男人远点，我要去拿猎枪。
But I thought it was not all men, because if it's not all men, then how come we see that common trope repeated time and time again where once a man has a daughter, the men around him are like, well, you better get a shotgun. Why? I thought it was not all men. So it is all men. So you agree. Yeah.
但我以为并非所有男人呢？因为如果不是所有男人，那为什么我们屡屡看到那种熟悉的桥段重演：一旦一个男人有了女儿，他周围的男人们就会说，你最好去弄把猎枪。为什么？我以为不是所有男人呢。所以其实是所有男人。所以你承认了。是的。
Are you a hypocrite or what's going on? No one's been able to give me the answer. Like what's the truth? Yeah. Like they literally are not people you can take seriously with your life, with your expenses, with your future until they prove otherwise. None of my messaging has ever been from the place of men are ultimately bad people. You're never going to find happiness.
你是个伪君子还是怎么回事？没有人能给我答案。到底什么是真相？是的。是的，在他们证明自己之前，你真的无法把他们当成能托付生活、开销和未来的人。我从来没有传达过“男人终究是坏人，你永远找不到幸福”这种观点。
Rather is that you have got to make your own effort as a person. to have a quality control system in place. And that involves a period of you being on your own for a while. You're not going to find the best guy for you by chance and by fluke. It's like it involves consciously listening and consciously watching that person's behavior to see if their words and their actions line up. It's a conscious effort. You can't just let it happen by chance.
相反，你的意思是作为一个人，你必须付出努力去建立一个质量控制系统。这包括一段时间的独处。你不会靠运气和巧合找到最适合你的男人。这需要你有意识地去倾听、有意识地去观察那个人的行为，看看他们的言行是否一致。这是一项有意识的努力。你不能只是顺其自然地让它发生。
Yeah. Oh, I absolutely agree. And like I have another friend who I think is an excellent example of this and has an amazing partner. And I think you're absolutely right. Like when you talk about we're not making, it's, your messaging has never been, well, we should create a female only commune and learn how to procreate on our own and like eradicate men. Like it's, it's not the messaging. It's that happiness, I think in many ways and happiness in relationships, especially if you're someone who dates men, has to come from a place of agency and has to come from a place of responsibility. And
是的。哦，我完全同意。比如我还有另一个朋友，我觉得她就是一个极好的例子，她有一个很棒的伴侣。我觉得你说的太对了。当我们谈论时，我们并没有，你的传达从来都不是：好吧，我们应该建立一个纯女性公社，学会自己生孩子繁衍后代，然后彻底消灭男人。这不是我们的宗旨。我们的宗旨是，幸福——在很多方面，尤其是亲密关系中的幸福，特别是如果你是一个和男性约会的人——必须源于自主权，必须源于责任感，并且
an accountability to yourself of like, okay, this is actually what I want. I can settle right now and I can be in a relationship in which I am deeply unhappy. My needs are unsatisfied. In some cases, it could even be oppressive or abusive. Or you can take the time to recondition yourself and relearn what you need to learn because I think that's the other thing, right? Like a lot of men are conditioned and men are indoctrinated, but women are equally told to be very passive and told to be nurturing and to overlook and that if they are lonely or if they are alone or if they are without a partner, that's something inherently wrong with them. And I don't think that that's the case. I would love to hear your perspective on how you go about that, like how you go about setting those
对自己负责，比如：“好吧，这其实才是我想要的。我现在可以妥协，可以进入一段让我深深感到痛苦的关系中。我的需求得不到满足。在某些情况下，它甚至可能是压迫性的或虐待性的。”或者，你可以花时间重新调理自己，重新学习你需要了解的知识，因为我认为这是另一回事，对吧？就像许多男人被社会规训和洗脑一样，女性同样被告知要非常被动，要懂得滋养他人，要学会忽视问题；如果她们感到孤独，如果她们孤身一人，或者没有伴侣，那就是她们本身有什么不对劲。我不认为情况是这样的。我很想听听你的看法，关于你是如何做到这一点的，比如你是如何设定
boundaries, how you go about selecting someone or vetting someone who is the right person for you. So for me, I have my non-negotiables and my non-negotiables are the type of non-negotiables that will warrant me getting the kind of email that Gemma got, where a man was. was sending her 1,000 words essentially telling her to go die. So my non-negotiables are definitely, you have to have, you have to have your finances together as a man. It doesn't sound very nice,
这些界限的，你是如何挑选或审查一个真正适合你的人的？对我来说，我有我的“底线”（non-negotiables），而我的底线正是那种会招致杰玛（Gemma）收到的那种电邮的底线——一个男人给发了一千字的电邮，本质上就是让她去死。所以我的底线绝对是：作为一个男人，你的财务状况必须过关。这听起来可能不太好听，
but that's the whole point. Like, you need to have that together because I'm not looking for a man who needs to be taken care of by me financially. I'm in a place where I'm taking care of myself financially, so it'll be nice to be partnered with somebody who has that area of their life sorted.
但这就是重点所在。你需要把这部分搞定，因为我可不希望找一个需要在财务上由我照顾的男人。我已经处于能够自己在财务上照顾好自己的阶段，所以能和一个在这方面生活理顺的人结为伴侣会很棒。
That doesn't mean that that person is going to be perfect just because their finances are sorted. I mean, we come across people all the time and stories in in the news all the time of people who come from wealth still experiencing depression. So part of why financial comfort matters to me is because having money alleviates a lot of problems and it allows me the ease to maneuver society and maneuver my life in a way that grants me access to the help I need. That's an excellent way to put it. Yes. And I think the least a man can do is bring ease to my life or else I'm better off just
这并不意味着这个人仅仅因为财务状况理顺了就完美无缺。我的意思是，我们时常遇到各种各样的人，新闻里也充斥着各种故事，那些出身富有的人依然经历着抑郁。所以，财务上的宽裕对我来说很重要的部分原因是，拥有金钱可以减轻很多问题，它能让我在社会和生活中游刃有余，从而让我能够获得我需要的帮助。这真是个极好的表达。是的。而且我认为男人能做的最起码的事情就是为我的生活带来轻松，否则我还不如
on my own really and just having friends that I'm generally enjoying my life with. Another non-negotiable for me is that he can't be a man that enjoys doing that whole gotcha moment thing men like to do, where they try and argue you out of your own ideologies when they call themselves male feminists. I gravitate towards men who live with those values. Most of the men who I know that actually exude feminist values don't call themselves feminists. They don't even engage with the theory or talk much about it. They just treat me and the women around them in a way that shows that they care and that this is a choice that they're making. Another non-negotiable for me is I can't be with a guy who is controlling. Whether a guy has money or not, you still need to be a really fucking awesome person and that has
一个人过，和那些能让我真正享受生活的朋友在一起。我的另一个底线是，他不能是一个喜欢玩弄男人热衷的那种“抓包游戏”（gotcha moment）的男人，他们试图在辩论中驳倒你自身的意识形态，却自称是“男性女性主义者”。我更倾向于那些以这些价值观生活的人。我认识的大多数真正散发着女性主义价值观的男人，其实并不自称女性主义者。他们甚至不参与理论探讨，也不怎么谈论这个。他们只是以一种展现出关心的方式对待我和周围的女性，并且这完全是他们主动做出的选择。我的另一个底线是，我不能和一个有控制欲的家伙在一起。不管一个男人有没有钱，你都必须是一个非常了不起的家伙，而这
to be an effort that you have put in by yourself. And when, you know, people hear me having this list of non-negotiables, the immediate instinct is how dare you? Like, as a woman, how dare you? How dare you decide that you are going to have a filtration system. But the real question should be why not? As somebody who sits on the anxious, ambivalent positioning of the attachment spectrum, I have to fight the hyper-independence that I have where I'm very used to being on my own. So actually, how I practice learning healthy interdependence is to accept care and accept help from people who love me.
必须是你自己付出努力得来的。当人们听到我列出这些底线时，他们的第一本能往往是：你怎么敢？作为一个女人，你怎么敢？你怎么敢决定自己要设立一个过滤系统？但真正的问题应该是：为什么不呢？作为一个处于焦虑-矛盾型依附光谱的人，我必须与自己内心的过度独立作斗争，因为我太习惯一个人生活了。所以实际上，我练习学习健康的相互依存的方式，就是去接受那些爱我的人给予的关怀和帮助。
So if I say I want a guy who has money, it's because I'm learning. to accept that I deserve help or learning to accept that I deserve support or learning to accept that I am worthy of somebody who wants to enable me to have an easy and fun life. And it happens for people all the time. And if it feels good, let it feel good until it doesn't. Like I don't believe in when things are in a nice place of a guy, constantly being like, but what if it goes wrong? But what if he does this?
所以如果我说我想找一个有钱的男人，那是因为我正在学习接受自己值得拥有帮助，或者学习接受自己值得拥有支持，或者学习接受自己值得拥有一个想要让我过上轻松有趣生活的人。这种事在生活中时常发生。如果感觉很好，那就让它感觉良好，直到它不再美妙为止。我不相信当事情处于一个男人的美好状态时，总是去想：“但万一出错了怎么办？但万一他做了这个怎么办？”
Rather, I'm going to let it feel good. And if he does something that shows otherwise, I'm also going to believe myself when I perceive that and I walk away knowing that, well, things are fun until they weren't and that's on you, buddy. You know what's interesting is that when you were talking about, like, I want to date men with who can support himself. Like, you don't have to provide reasoning for that. You know what I mean?
相反，我会让它感觉很好。如果他做出了相反的事情，当我察觉到这一点时，我也会相信自己的直觉，然后潇洒转身，心想：好吧，事情原本挺有意思的，直到它变得没意思，那是你的问题，老兄。你知道有趣的是，当你谈到“我想和能养活自己的男人约会”时，你根本不需要为此给出理由。你知道我的意思吗？
Like, I feel like often when I give my non-negotiables, maybe you find the same, I'm like, oh, but it's for these reasons. Yes. It's for these reasons that I want this. And it's like, why can't I just say that that's what I want? Why can't I just make that stuff? And as someone who has, I'm in a completely out myself here, only ever dated men who are not financially stable. And should dare not judge me.
就像，我觉得通常当我列出自己的底线时，也许你也有同感，我会想：“哦，但我是出于这些原因才这样的。”是的。我是出于这些原因才想要这样的。这就好像，为什么我不能仅仅说“这就是我想要的”？为什么我不能直接……作为一个——我在这里完全豁出去了——只和在财务上不稳定的男人约过会的人，大家千万别评判我。
I'm learning. I'm not judging because it be like that. I know. And you just like so spoke to my soul there where it was like, because I am so hyper independent that there's someone who I can mother. And I'm able to make the financial decisions in some way. I, I, I, the men that I've dated have never had jobs. Isn't that ridiculous? I've, I taught one of them how to drive, multiple of them, how to drive. And I think it's because I naturally seek this matriarch or maternal role with these men. And I've had to one learn that, you know, I'm actually not your mother. I'm actually your partner. I'm your romantic interest. I remember one, time going on a trip with someone and I paid for the entire thing. And he paid for one thing, one thing. And it was something that we actually didn't end up using. And he started complaining
我在学习。我没有评判，因为现实往往就是这样。我懂。你刚才的话真的深深触动了我的心灵，因为我实在太过度独立了，以至于我总会找一个我可以去“母亲般照顾”的男人。而且我在某种程度上能够做出财务决策。我——我约会过的男人从来都没有工作。这难道不荒谬吗？我曾教过其中一个学开车，教了好几个学开车。我想这是因为我自然而然地在这些男人身上寻求这种大家长或母性的角色。我不得不经历一个过程，首先要明白：其实我不是你的母亲。我其实是你的伴侣。我是你的恋爱对象。我记得有一次，
about how, you know, we didn't use that. We didn't like end up using that thing. I think it was like a fruit. I think it was like a freeze dried meal. We were like camping or something like that. And he was like, we didn't use that. Like my contribution went to waste. And now I look at it and I was like, oh my God, I completely changed you. Meanwhile, you paid for the bulk of it. I paid for everything. And I was like, okay, but you actually never said thank you. And also, I now realize I would rather not do that.
我和某人去旅行，我付了全部费用。而他只付了一样东西，一样东西。而且那东西我们最后根本没用上。他开始抱怨说，你知道的，我们没用上那个。我们最后没有用那东西。我记得那好像是一种水果。我觉得那好像是一包冻干食品。我们当时在露营还是什么的。他说，我们没用过那个。我的钱白出了。现在回想起来，我心想：天哪，我完全在迁就你。与此同时，大头都是你付的？我付了一切。我心想：好吧，但你其实从来都没说过谢谢。而且我也意识到，我宁愿不要这样。
And I don't need to give you a reason. I don't need to give anyone a reason. This is just the standard that I'm setting for my life, the same way that men are able to create standards for their life and no one ever questions it. So I just think it's one of those things that has... No one's ever made a man explain. Okay, so when you say you don't like fat women,
我不需要给你任何理由。我不需要给任何人理由。这只是我为自己的人生设定的标准，就像男人们能够为自己的人生设定标准而从来没有人会去质疑一样。所以我觉得这正是那种……从来没有人逼一个男人解释：“好吧，当你大谈特谈你不喜欢胖女人时，
what does that mean? Or when you say that you're the head of the household, what does that mean and how can you validate? Everyone just accepts it and you see women literally losing weight for men. You see women literally who are career women making themselves smaller for men. You see women who are like us,
那是什么意思？”或者当你大谈特谈自己是一家之主时，“那是什么意思，你又该如何证明？”每个人都照单全收，你可以看到女人们为了男人拼命减肥。你可以看到身为职业女性的女性为了男人而让自己变得渺小。你可以看到像我们这样
super accomplished, like you explain in your story, dating men who are far below your level and it almost feels like you have to make up for how far behind they are by cutting yourself into smaller pieces. And that's still not enough. It's still not enough for them. That's why I'm like,
超级成功的女性，正如你在故事中解释的那样，去和那些远远低于你水平的男人约会，这感觉就像你不得不通过把自己切成更小的碎片，来弥补他们落后你太多的差距。然而这仍然不够。这对他们来说还是远远不够。这就是为什么我觉得，
you're better off on your own live in that healthy cynicism of knowing that most men are not built to even live up to your greatness but the men who are built to live up to your greatness are out there you have to keep open to that but also you need to expose yourself
你还不如一个人过，带着那种健康的冷嘲热讽——清醒地认识到大多数男人甚至根本不配匹配你的伟大，但那些能够匹配你伟大的男人确实存在，你必须对此保持开放的心态，但同时你也需要让自己置身于
to environments where you're likely to meet those kinds of men for you to even meet the kind of man that you envision yourself being with do you have the confidence to hold your own do you have the confidence to believe that you're worthy of the kind of man that you deep down deserve
那些更有可能遇到这类男人的环境中。为了能遇到你心中设想的那种伴侣，你有自信坚持自我吗？你有自信相信自己配得上内心深处真正值得拥有的那种男人吗？
because if you've only been tolerating men you have to look after and you finally come across a guy who actually has the means to bring this experience to your life that you've been longing for. Anyway, so you've got enough, if men feel bold enough to ask you for pussy, don't be scared to ask them for shit either. We're scared to ask men for staff. Meanwhile, they are extracting emotional labour for us from us every day and we're teaching them to drive for free.
因为如果你一直以来只是在迁就那些需要你照顾的男人，而你终于遇到了一个真正有能力将你一直渴望的那种生活体验带进你生命中的家伙时……总之，既然男人们都觉得有底气向你要逼，那你也别害怕向他们要这要那。我们总是害怕向男人开口要东西。与此同时，他们每天都在榨取我们的情感劳动力，而我们却在免费教他们开车。
Don't add me on that. Meanwhile, we're scared to look. No, but it's real. There are some, I've been there. I've been, most of my dating history until I realized who I was, was me picking man that I had to look after because it's about control as well. It's about feeling like, well, this guy can't leave me because look at what I've done for him. Well, jokes on you because you can do everything for a man and he will still leave you.
别把那算在我头上。与此同时，我们又害怕去面对。不，但这确实是真的。有些情况，我以前也经历过。在我意识到真正的自我之前，我的大部分恋爱史，其实都是我去挑选那些我不得不照顾的男人，因为这同样关乎控制欲。这关乎一种感觉，那就是，好吧，这家伙是绝对离不开我的，因为你看我为他付出了多少。好吧，其实小丑竟是你自己，因为你可以为男人付出一切，但他最后还是会抛弃你。
Oh, yeah. And you'll be beside yourself. Like, how? I know. Oh, my gosh. Gerard. I just feel like you've, like, peered into my brain. And I don't think it was, oh my God, that is so painful.
哦，是的。而且你会感到不知所措。比如，怎么会这样？我懂。哦，天哪。杰勒德。我只是觉得你好像看穿了我的大脑。而且我觉得这并不是，哦天哪，这太痛苦了。
I don't think it was a control thing, right? Like, I don't think I was sitting out there being like this. I think it's the thing where it's like exactly what you were saying. Like people just, there are people who are going to meet in your life, romantic interests, or whoever, who are going to want to give you what you give to others. And I think sometimes I find it so unnatural to be like, okay, well, this is actually what I love doing for people. I love giving them everything, like being really generous with my final. finances with my time, with my energy, how come I can't accept that they might want to give that back?
我不认为这是一种控制欲，对吧？也就是说，我不觉得我当时坐在这里会有这种想法。我觉得这就像你刚才说的那样。生活中总会遇到一些人，比如恋爱对象或其他人，他们会想要回馈你给予别人的那种付出。而我觉得有时候，要我去接受这一点会让我觉得很不自然，比如，好吧，其实这正是我喜欢为别人做的事。我喜欢给予他们一切，比如在财务、时间和精力上都非常慷慨，为什么我就不能接受他们也想要这样回报我呢？
And how come it's hard for me to realize that? And, you know, you can call it personality, you can call it your upbringing, whatever it is. I just think it's something that you have to unlearn. And when you do get to the point of being able to be realistic about, you know, what you expect from others and what you're willing to accept from others, everything becomes a lot easier. And you are able to establish those relationships that are two-sided. Right. And even what you were saying about being someone that it's in your nature to be generous and giving, I'm the same. And to anybody who's listening who might be thinking, so should I just like stop being a generous person and like stop sharing? No, just be more conscious of who you share that side of yourself around. That's it. That's how you have a quality control process. Like, you don't have to stop being who you are. You just have to learn that some men only deserve the 30 day free trial version of you. And once that 30 day free trial version of you. And once that 30 day free trial, trial has ended, they'll be blocked out of nowhere. Like, you got your trial, you didn't do much with it. Sorry, dude. Like, got to keep moving now. Your free trial has actually expired.
为什么我很难意识到这一点？你可以把它归咎于性格，也可以归咎于你的成长环境，无论是什么原因。我只是觉得这是你需要去克服和摒弃的东西。当你终于能够现实地看待你对别人的期望以及你愿意接受别人怎样的对待时，一切都会变得容易得多。你将能够建立起那些双向奔赴的关系。没错。就像你刚才说的，慷慨和给予是你的天性，我也是这样。对于任何正在收听、可能会想“那我难道应该停止做一个慷慨的人、停止分享吗”的人，我想说：不，你只是需要对自己把这一面展现给什么样的人更加清醒。就这么简单。这就是你的质量控制流程。你不需要停止做真实的自己。你只需要明白，有些男人只配拥有你的30天免费试用期。一旦这30天免费试用期结束，他们就会莫名其妙地被拉黑。就像是，你已经体验过试用版了，但也没怎么好好利用它。抱歉啦，老兄。我们要继续前进了。你的免费试用期实际上已经过期了。
These guys don't deserve that goddess mother nature energy. Like, save that, please save that for the dude that has worked too for Nel for it because that energy you have can change a man's life. Dude from across the street wearing a checkered thermal shirt. and vans does not deserve that. He will be fine. He will be fine. If you was to, God forbid, fall down and die right now, he will find somebody else to provide him with the supply that he's looking for.
这些家伙根本不配得到那种女神母亲大自然般的能量。留着它，请把这种能量留给那些真正为此付出过努力的男人，因为你拥有的这种能量真的可以改变一个男人的生活。街对面那个穿着格子保暖衫和Vans帆布鞋的家伙根本不配。他会过得很好的。他会好好的。如果，上帝保佑，你现在突然倒下死去了，他也会立刻找到另一个人来为他提供他所需要的情绪价值。
I feel like this is a really good place to wrap up. Because if you're not tired of us already, if you... I know. But I'm going to promise this to my listeners right now, we will be doing a part two. Because this was such an engaging conversation. Oh, hell yeah. Prepare to be sick.
我觉得这是一个非常好的收尾时机。因为如果你们现在还没对我们感到厌烦的话，如果你们……我懂的。不过我要向我的听众保证，我们一定会做第二期节目。因为这次的对话实在是太引人入胜了。哦，太棒了。准备好听吐吧。
of us. I honestly, I only just looked at the time then and I was like, oh my God, we have been speaking for an hour and a half about everything and anything. And I think that's just an amazing thing. And I hope that you have enjoyed whoever's listening to this being a fly on the wall for this conversation. And if you found it controversial, well, I'm so sorry, come back for part two and we can enlighten you a little bit more. I was just going to say on my end that I really hope that anybody who's listening who resonated with this and is maybe in a stage of realizing that they deserve better, do not try and take extreme steps to completely transform your life overnight. This is a process. Baby steps are still steps. Take your time because detaching from any
我们聊得太投入了。老实说，我刚才看了一眼时间，心想，天哪，我们已经天南海北地聊了一个半小时。我觉得这真的是一件很神奇的事。我希望无论谁在听这段对话，都能像一只墙上的苍蝇一样享受其中。如果你觉得这很有争议，好吧，我深表歉意，那就回来听第二期吧，我们会为你带来更多启发。我只想顺便说一句，我真心希望任何听到这里并对此产生共鸣、或许正处于意识到自己值得更好对待这一阶段的人，千万不要试图采取极端步骤在一夜之间彻底改变你的生活。这是一个过程。微小的步伐也依然是步伐。慢慢来，因为与任何
kind of abuser is literally like removing chewing gum from a denim jacket. You have to be really careful. It's a very intricate process and be kind to yourself because there will be relapses, but just know that with each relapse, you're still progressing. So just focus on moving forward every day and remembering that one day it's not going to be like this anymore. And that's the day you just got to keep living for. Yeah, that's a beautiful way to put it. I think that's exactly spot on.
类型的施虐者剥离关系，简直就像是从牛仔夹克上撕下口香糖一样艰难。你必须非常小心。这是一个非常错综复杂的过程，请对你自己好一点，因为中间可能会出现反复，但要知道，每一次反复都说明你仍在前进。所以，只需专注于每天向前迈进，并记住总有一天情况不会再是这样了。这就是你必须坚持活下去的那一天。是的，这个比喻太美妙了。我觉得完全切中要害。
You know, there's nothing in life that's promised other than change and there will be a day that you feel all right. So I want to thank to Didera for her amazing insights. And I'm going to just say her podcast, is one of the best I've ever listened to. It is incredible. Thank you so much. And it's honestly true.
你知道，生活中除了变化之外，没有什么事是百分之百承诺的，总有一天你会觉得一切都好起来了。所以我要感谢奇代拉（Chidera）分享她精彩的见解。我只想说，她的播客是我听过的最好的播客之一。简直不可思议。非常感谢。而且这绝对是真心话。
I've been listening to it on my way to work, at work. And I just think that if you enjoyed this conversation, even if there were times where you didn't agree with what we were saying, just go and listen to it. Because I just feel like it is essential listening for anyone, especially women who are in their 20s, who are dealing with the same questions that we grappled today. So, Chedera, thank you so much for coming on.
我一直在上班的路上以及工作时听它。我真的觉得，如果你喜欢这次的对话，即使有时候你可能不同意我们的某些观点，也一定要去听听她的节目。因为我觉得这对于任何人来说都是必听的节目，尤其是那些二十多岁、正在处理我们今天所纠结的同样问题的女性。所以，奇代拉，非常感谢你能来。
Thank you for having me, Gemma. And to anybody who's curious about my podcast, The Slumflower Hour, it's essentially for any woman who dates men that is a little disobedient. Like, if you're a disobedient woman who deep down, you just, you need that enabling to step into your power, then the Slumflower Hour is the podcast for you. But until then, I give you my love. Thank you for listening to this incredible conversation.
谢谢邀请我来，杰玛。任何对我的播客《The Slumflower Hour》感兴趣的人，这档节目基本上就是为那些在恋爱中有点“不听话”的女性准备的。如果你是一个内心深处渴望获得赋能、从而能够掌控自己力量的“叛逆”女性，那么《The Slumflower Hour》就是为你量身打造的播客。不过在此之前，我把爱送给你们。感谢收听这场精彩的对话。
with myself and Gemma, and I hope that this has sparked enlightening you to remember that you deserve to choose the life that you live rather than settle for it. Yeah. Thank you so much. And just a reminder, if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. And if you want to be involved with the community, if you want to follow along, see when merchandise is released, new episodes are released, Please follow at that psychology podcast. And I hope you have a lovely day. Thank you for listening.
我和杰玛的这次交流，我希望这能点燃你们心中的启迪，让你们记住：你值得选择自己想要的生活，而不是将就。是的。非常感谢大家。顺便提醒一下，如果你确实喜欢这一集，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何平台上留下五星好评。如果你想加入这个社群，想要一路关注，了解周边商品何时发售、新单集何时上线，请关注 at that psychology podcast。希望你们有个美好的一天。谢谢收听。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难一课》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主播基尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人披着一副盔甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：别想轻易招惹我。但仅仅因为你具备这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《艰难一课》。在2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两次，对吗？我只伪造了一次检测结果。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名男同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子彻底炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是数字 2%，请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个高产的骗子时，
They take matters into their own hands. I vowed I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
她们决定亲自采取行动。我发誓我一定要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请收听《闺蜜们》（The Girlfriends）。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档iHeart播客。真人真事，品质保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。